[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment vous vous sentez hamilton
c'est absolument génial d'être de retour à
hamilton bonsoir hamilton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons trois sièges sans titulaires
les trois sièges sont des circonscriptions swing
chaque
partie des trois principaux partis  croit
qu'ils pourraient le capturer s'ils peuvent obtenir
leur vote ils croient qu'ils pourraient
gagner je vous dis que j'étais à hamilton est
la nuit dernière c'était fantastique nick
milanovich
est c'est un sac à dos d'opération et ce
que nous faisons ici est nous
fournitures que nous les mettons dans des
sacs à dos que nous distribuons aux écoles
et aux étudiants dont les familles n'auront pas
l'argent pour acheter ce nécessaire,
vous savez, l'équipement et l'équipement pour l'
éducation, nous devons faire de notre mieux,
nous sommes catégoriques sur le fait que nous sommes  va leur enlever
des sièges au gouvernement bien les
hamiltoniens sont ouverts d'esprit quand il
s'agit du ndp ils nous écoutent
parce que nous parlons de leurs
problèmes beaucoup de gens de la classe ouvrière à
hamilton nous
nous efforçons de représenter  nt la classe
ouvrière dans son intérêt,
nous occupons le siège depuis 15 ans, j'ai
travaillé aux côtés du député sortant
et j'ai grandi ici, euh, vous
savez pourquoi nous avons un avantage à garder ce
siège,
il y a tous ces nouveaux  les propriétaires qui
ont emménagé ici, en
particulier de toronto et
du conservatoire de la région de peel,
merci beaucoup, nous nous sommes rapprochés
de 1600 votes,
soit huit personnes par poteau,
c'est tout si nous pouvons trouver deux
familles et demie de plus par poteau, ce serait
il y a eu une autre histoire il y a aussi de
nouvelles personnes qui arrivent la
démographie change
le nouveau sélecteur
les
gens de la forêt de toronto ne peuvent pas se permettre quatre années de plus d'une
crise du logement nous sommes là avec une
stratégie nationale du logement très ambitieuse le
coût de la vie pro à hamilton a
enquête montée en flèche
[Musique]